solo what's not Troye Sivan yes oh my
god you're doing it right okay first of
all let's talk about your blue hair okay
do blue hair people have more fun yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah it's a vibe
honestly specifically just shorter hair
I had like longer hair it was like I
just like constantly I don't know got
the print was just annoying so it's just
nice to like not think about it well
you're really Kelly here as well yeah I
got really curly hair I'm like I feel
like your curls they like naturally do
no matter what you do they look - op'
thank you my like they like dry in a
weird way and then it's like yes it's
all crazy so what inspired you to want
to go blue I mean that conscious love I
just love blue yeah and I use like yeah
blues just one of my favorite cars I
mean I use it a lot of like my like
artwork and stuff
and yeah so it was just something I
wanted to do for a while I guess and
then reaction is your reaction when you
saw his hair blue I feel like it belongs
on his head like I really do thank you
looks like I'm really quickly or what
but I think it looks awesome yeah you
have really nice eyes I feel like you
could make your hair the color of your
eyes you guys could just do a little
thing together loose yeah maybe one day
mm-hmm okay it's kind of like the shirt
the shirt I regret not because I was
blond
I should have before I went back to
brunette I should have just like put in
a temporary washer would have been so
easy yeah so I should have done like a
crazy color for a second but whatever
next time next time so the last time we
saw you actually was in Chris like
Christmas time and you were singing all
about love now I mean what happened give
me the key no I mean I just I put out a
bunch of songs they were about love and
and I'm top I'm so tired you're tired
I'm so tired of love songs from all the
songs you've already put out exactly or
did something happen no no it's just
yeah that's hard okay okay all right
so a singer well it's just one of those
places here mm okay hmm
so had singer songwriters obviously you
guys write about your personal life
um would you say it's more tough or
therapeutic to write about you know
heartbreak or
would you say therapeutic yeah for me
definitely therapeutic I think like well
it also depends though because it's like
if you write a bad song
that in itself like regardless of what
else you're going through in your life
that'll like knock you right down you're
like I am terrible my job why am i doing
what I'm doing like I suck kind of thing
so it can it can be the worst thing ever
but then if you can channel that and
have like that magic moment where you
make something that you're proud of that
sounds like uniquely you I will like
ride that high for days you know I'll
feel amazing for like a week after I've
written a good song so it can definitely
help you process that it's kind of it is
a therapy session because you really
have to sit with yourself and be like
how do I feel about this you know yeah
yeah yeah sometimes you know you like
also in turn about writing a bad song
sometimes like I'll write a song and I
like over romanticize it I'm like
polished this is how I really feel like
yeah yeah yeah I think you tweeted
something about that just being in your
own head yes yeah but you guys make
great records so I mean thank you you
know do you prefer to write about love
or heartbreak
I'm much I feel like I'm yeah I feel
like I typically would be more suited to
write about heartbreak I feel like the
two go hand-in-hand you know I mean so
often you don't you get the one after
you've had the other kind of thing and
you're like yeah for me I that was
something that I was excited to do for
my second album because I had always
written like these kind of sad
melancholy songs just because that was
what I was feeling or what I was
attracted to and then with my second
album I was like I just feel really
happy and like what does that sound like
I've never really tried so that was a
fun a fun experiment yeah I feel like a
lot of singers go through things and
when they're going through something
dark they're like hold on to it this is
gonna be a really good song you know and
it's kind of cool like that
so do you guys ever have maybe like a
subject when you're writing that you're
like I just don't want to go there I
know you guys are super close but in
creating music together is there like
and I really want to say that bro I
don't
talk about that we had a little like I
feel like I had to push for the buzzcut
season Larry oh yeah there's a lyric in
the song that it was just like too real
for a second but yeah I got there yeah
you got you got there you definitely got
that did you get hustled is that what's
happening no I was just like pulling
from like a past relationship that up
you know that I pulled from many many
times and you start to just be like like
and then you get tired of doing that
you're just like this is like I don't
know is this like sick yeah it's kind of
like pulling details it was like real
things but then you're kind of like you
you start to feel that I don't know you
just start for me like I got like
conscious of it and I'm like is this
like mean or is this like not cool like
I'm yeah but yeah so buzzcut season that
song as many feels yeah maybe feels so
talking about the single I heard that it
was an accidental duet is that true and
then ii whose idea was it to blend your
voices together it wasn't accidental
yeah we just wrote the song together
yeah and then was it your idea yeah I
wasn't gonna be like me on the song hey
tree would you be
would you maybe but consider please
consider potential even know I was so
excited when he asked me just cuz I
loved the song yeah and I'm so proud to
be a part of it in any way shape or form
but very excited to have my voice on
there too yeah it's so rare for artists
these days to make a duet and actually
be in the studio together right so what
was it like for you to stuff I mean we
made we made another song earlier that
day that was not good no never come out
yep but it was kinda like what we had to
do to just kind of like break the ice a
little bit on the songwriting front and
then yeah and then we kind of spent the
rest of day like should make chilling my
backyard writing and working on lyrics
and stuff with yes Leland and yeah I
think the cool thing is I don't want to
speak for you but it feels like I feel
like this about myself I'm like
songwriter first and I feel the same way
about you you know what I mean like the
the craft of writing is something that I
think we both really really
about and love you know that process so
to be able to like sit down and and nerd
out with someone that you really admire
and you know create something together
it's it's really really fun it's awesome
who's more of a perfectionist out of you
- yeah I remember you talking about like
getting a mix back and there was some
like we had frequency on something that
like only yeah and maybe like a couple
dogs good here yeah and but that like I
don't know I would notice yeah I
definitely like freaky perfectionist in
that way yeah so fans are loving the
record the record is so so catchy it's
so great what does it feel like to see
how it's resonated with fans just how
does that feel for you guys I mean it's
been awesome it's just been like so
crazy I feel like we just kind of put
the song out I felt like releasing a
bird or something like you just we just
let it go anyways I've been like we like
just going to Z and like I like that
image
seriously it felt like we were like
holding it down and then it was like and
it's just like really resonating with
you I don't think I've ever had a song
resonate like this so immediately we got
so many people it's it's been really
cool yeah super super thankful it's
crazy yeah is there a chance that you
guys would make a full-length album
together oh my god thank you can you
match no I don't mean I would be down I
I've always wanted to do like some sort
of side project like maybe we should
make a band or something I see I've
wanted to make like a like an EP or
something yeah I definitely to do some
side projects like when I want to do
some type of a boy band like a
non-traditional boy band cool with like
other people yeah like we should I've
always wanted to do an entire ap with my
voice pitched down love it or like you
know when you mess with the foeman yeah
like I think we showed you that and
making up a new artist name and just
like putting it out just to kind of take
the pressure off of like having to sound
like yourself you know I'm really giving
yourself the freedom to do whatever yeah
I would be down to do something like
that with you who would you guys recruit
for the boy band this
I'm not in charge of the boy man yeah
first I'm hearing of it yeah I don't
like one person in particular that
you're like I'd be kind of fun um I was
honestly just try to do it like some of
my friends that I write songs with yeah
I don't know shortly I haven't really
thought about yeah
Shawn Mendes the frontman oh we love him
yes come on Canada yeah that was a
dignity for us yeah
you